Schmid am Ende, DT?
Ja wohl, ja wohl, mit DT am Ende.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 75 Jahre alt.
Und 70, okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
10. Mai 1947.
Okay.
Wie ist die Wegen?
Ich wiege ungefähr 80 Kilo.
80. Und wie groß sind Sie denn?
1,75 m.
Ja, 1,75 m.
Frau Uta, habe ich recht oder?
Nein, Uta ist der Vorname, Schmid ist der Nachname, immer.
Okay, Frau Schmidt, habe ich recht?
Frau Schmidt, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Was für Beschwerte haben Sie denn?
Es ist so, dass ich Schmerzen habe im Rücken.
Rücken schmerzen.
Rücken schmerzen und die Beine und die Oberschenkel tun mir weh.
Okay.
Oberschenkel.
Ja, seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerte?
Das ist jetzt so seit 3 Tagen schlimmer geworden.
Okay.
Aber haben Sie diese Beschwerte seit 3 Tagen?
Ungefähr so seit 3 Tagen schlimmer geworden.
Okay.
Aber haben Sie diese Beschwerte seit 3 Tagen?
Ungefähr seit 3 Tagen.
Okay.
Ja.
Sind Sie schmerzen oder sind Sie bewerblich?
Die beiden Schmerzen sind anders.
Und die Rücken schmerzen bzw. schmerzen mehr auf der rechten Seite, die ich habe.
Rechten Seite.
Okay.
Und London-Beräusch oder Brust-Beräusch?
Ich weiß nicht, was Sie damit meinen.
Ich meine Oberste-Teil oder Unterste-Teil des Rücken.
Mitte.
Okay.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Auf einer Schmerz-Klampe.
Die sind sehr stark.
Sehr stark.
Manchmal ist es so stark, dass es so richtig weh tut.
Und dann geht das wieder kurz weg.
Es kommt und geht.
Okay.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Wie meinen Sie das eingenommen?
Das Medikament.
Ich meinte.
Ein Medikament, nicht das Medikament.
Nein, ich war noch nicht beim Arzt.
Ich komme jetzt direkt zu Ihnen.
Okay.
Weil das so stark ist, hat mein Sohn gesagt, ich muss jetzt ins Krankenhaus.
Krankenhaus, okay.
Wie fühlen Sie sich momentan?
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Oder haben Sie kältisch weiß?
Ich bin schlab, ich bin müde.
Ich glaube, ich habe auch Fieber.
Mir geht es nicht gut.
Ich bin richtig schlapp.
Seit wann fühlen Sie sich müde?
Ja, das hat jetzt zugenommen.
Es hat vor drei Tagen angefangen und ich bin jetzt richtig müde.
Okay.
Haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Ja, ich habe es zu Hause, mein Sohn hat es gemessen.
Er hat gesagt, ich habe fast 39,2 hat er gesagt.
Über 39?
39.
Sie haben nichts eingenommen dagegen.
Nein, ich bin sofort zu Ihnen gekommen.
Sie haben gut gemacht, ja, zum Schauen.
Sind alle Beschwerden langsam oder plöstisch aufgetreten?
Ja, langsam. Vor drei Tagen eben.
Hat es langsam angefangen und jetzt ist es so, dass ich nicht mehr stehen kann vor Schmerzen.
Wenn die kommen, das kommt und geht.
Okay.
Wie verstärkt und verbessert?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass Werme ein bisschen gut tut.
Nein, das sieht alles ganz normal aus.
Ja, Frau Schmidt, ist diese Beschwerde zum ersten Mal aufgetreten?
Diese Beschwerde geht nicht.
Sind diese Beschwerden?
Ja, ich habe das zum ersten Mal.
Zum ersten Mal, okay.
Sie haben auch Fieber.
Haben Sie Schüttel oder Nachtschweiß?
Nachtschwitzig nicht, aber ich schüttel richtig.
Schütteln.
Haben Sie dafür eine Astöser bemerkt?
Nein.
Okay.
Husten Sie?
Bitte?
Husten habe ich nicht. Nein, ich husse nicht.
Okay.
Oder haben Sie Atemnot?
Nein, ich habe nur Schmerzen.
Schmerzen.
Okay.
Ja.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder...
Nein, habe ich nicht.
...Pulspennaut bei Ihnen?
Hab ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Sie haben kein Schwindel?
Genau, Sie haben kein Schwindel?
Ja, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit, Frau Schmidt?
Ähm, ja, jetzt bin ich krank.
Jetzt habe ich natürlich keinen Appetit, weil es mir nicht gut geht,
aber vorher hatte ich keine Probleme mit dem Appetit.
Okay.
Aber jetzt, seit drei Tagen, ich esse kaum, das ist überhaupt kein Appetit mehr.
Wegen da.
Ja, in drei Tagen habe ich schon sehr viel abgenommen.
Okay.
Ich weiß nicht, aber ich merke, dass die Hosen einfach viel weiter geworden sind.
Und haben Sie oder schlafen Sie gut wegen dieser Schmerzen?
Vielleicht ist alles geht Ihnen gut.
Allerweiser habe ich keine Schlafprobleme,
aber jetzt natürlich kann ich nicht schlafen,
weil ich diese Schmerzen...
Heute Nacht habe ich kaum geschlafen, deswegen bin ich ja hierher gekommen.
Vorher war das nicht so schlimm.
Ja.
Können Sie andere Extremitäten gut bewegen?
Haben Sie eine Bewegung ein, Schenkom?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Das haben Sie klippeln, taub heizt gefühlt,
oder Kraftverlust bei Ihnen bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht bemerkt.
Eine.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Schmidt, ich würde gerne ab über Ihre Folgen etwas wissen.
Leiden Sie an Irgendwärschchen für Erkrankungen.
Ich meine Bluthochdruck, Bluthochdruck,
oder Knokunschwund.
Ich höre nicht Sie.
Bluthochdruck ablesen.
Okay, seit wann?
Seit wann haben Sie?
Das habe ich schon sehr lange.
Ich bin ja schon so alt, ich habe das schon sehr lange.
Ja.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ja Blutdruck gemessen?
Ich möchte mich messen, jeden Tag, morgens und abends.
Und das war eigentlich so, wie es sein soll.
Alles in Ordnung, oder?
Ja, alles in Ordnung.
Okay.
Ich habe eine Medikamente.
Ja, ich nehme Kandesatan, 60, 16 Milligramm, einmal am Tag.
16.
Noch mal 16.
Okay.
Und dann nehme ich noch Metroprol, 50 Milligramm, morgens eine.
Metroprol ist Wahnsinn, morgens eine.
Metroprol 20 gibt es nicht, Metroprol 50.
50.
Ja, Metroprol gibt es nur als 47,5 oder 50, 20 gibt es nicht.
Okay.
Metroprol 50, morgens eine und das war es eigentlich, die beiden Medikamente.
Nein, Sie haben weiterer Erkrankung.
Aus dem...
Das.
Eigentlich hält mir jetzt wegen den Schmerzen, die ich so stark habe, nicht so viel ein.
Ich habe jetzt so starker Schmerzen, wieder, jetzt kommt es wieder.
Ja, fragst du.
Jetzt kommt es wieder, jetzt kommt es wieder.
Doll ich Ihnen Schmerz mit der Liebe?
Ja, bitte.
Ich halse mich aus.
Hab unsere ihr ganz wahrscheinlich allergegegen Medikamente geschmeint.
Ja, ich habe eine Novalgienalergie.
Novalgien, okay.
Ja, Sie haben nichts genommen.
Okay.
Ich gebe Ihnen jetzt eine Medikamente in die Weine.
Schmerz mit der...
Bitte.
Fühlen Sie sich besser.
Okay.
Ja.
Gut.
Und wurden Sie bisher operiert?
Ich hatte einen Kaiserschnitt bei der Geburt von meinem Sohn.
Kaiser-Schimpfopoulation.
Ja.
Seit wann?
Wann war das?
Mein Sohn ist 37 Jahre alt vor 37 Jahren.
Okay.
Ja, fragst du.
Gehen Sie regelmäßig Fraunas?
Zum Fraunas, zum Iran Fraunas?
Nein.
Okay.
Ich muss ehrlich sein, nein.
Wissen Sie nicht, ob Sie eine...
Das letzte Mal vor fünf Jahren und vor fünf Jahren war alles in Ordnung.
Das war aber vor fünf Jahren.
Und seitdem bin ich nicht gegangen.
Ich muss ehrlich sein.
Okay.
Wie lange haben Sie das?
Früher, ja. Früher habe ich geraucht.
Aber ich rauche schon seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr.
Okay.
Und Sie haben Zigaretten geraucht.
Zigaretten, habe ich das?
Genau.
Zigaretten geraucht, ja.
Zigaretten geraucht.
Okay.
Wie lange haben Sie das?
Wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Ja, wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Genau. Ich habe bestimmt 20 Jahre geraucht.
Ich habe 20 Jahre geraucht.
Eine Packung am Tag, 20 Jahre lang habe ich geraucht.
Okay.
Denken Sie Alkohol?
Nur Beigelegenheit.
Beigelegenheit.
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht per Sonne,
das ist eine Routinefrage.
Sie haben sie erfahrt, wie kann man sie drogen?
Drogen? Nein.
Nein.
Sie haben eine neue Anarchie.
Sie haben eine Quartere.
Oder haben Sie Unverträglichkeit?
Gegen Lebensmittel oder Medikamente?
Unverträglichkeiten.
Gegen über Medikamente oder Lebensmittel.
Ich habe nur eine Laktorin Tolerant.
Ich habe keine Allergen.
Sonst habe ich auch sonst keine Allergen.
Außer Norwayin Allergen.
Okay.
Ja, jetzt würde gerne über ihre Familiengesicht etwas wissen.
Nein, die Frage noch mal stellen, bitte.
Ja, gibt es wichtige Vorerkrankungen in ihrer Familie?
Ja, sehr gut.
Ich habe einen Sohn, der ist gesund.
Meine Eltern sind natürlich verstorben.
Meine Mutter hatte einen Sohn,
meine Vater war gesund.
Wie sind Sie verstorben?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Da war ich noch zu klein.
Ich weiß es leider nicht.
Wie alt war sie?
Ich weiß nicht.
Was haben Sie als Beruflöschen gemacht?
Noch mal, die Frage noch mal stellen, bitte.
Was haben Sie als beruflöschen gemacht?
Ja, nicht als beruflöschen gemacht, ne?
Ja.
Was haben Sie als Beruf ausgeübt, kann man sagen?
Aber nicht als beruflöschen gemacht, was haben Sie beruflöschen gemacht?
Ehrlich gesagt war ich Hausfrau.
Ich war Hauskauf.
Bittem war ich in Hauskauf.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Ist Ihre Mann gesund?
Ja, der ist gesund. Gott sei Dank.
Gott sei Dank.
Sie haben einen Sohn.
Haben Sie Stress?
Ja, alltägliche Stress.
Oder Privat?
Ich habe Stress, aber Privat.
Privatleben, ja.
Nichts.
Ich habe mich verheiratet.
Ich habe etwas zu tun.
Auf Dem
Entschuldigung, ja, okay. Das ist ein Schmerz, der ist in meinem Rücken und der ist wie ein Gürtel, habe ich das Gefühl, als ob mich einer mit dem Gürtel zusammenschnürmen würde.
Wie ein Gürtel.
Aber es ist vor allen Dingen auf der rechten Seite.
Rechten.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ich stehe in letzter Zeit sehr oft Wasser lassen, ja.
Okay.
Wie oft gehen Sie auf die Toilette?
Das habe ich nicht gezählt, aber sehr oft. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin ständig auf der Toilette.
Okay.
Früher hatten Sie einen Nierenprobleme?
Noch mal die Frage stellen, bitte.
Haben Sie früher Probleme gehabt?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Blut öhring gemacht?
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin ständig auf der Toilette.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin ständig auf der Toilette,
aber ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin ständig auf der Toilette.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin ständig auf der Toilette.
Nein, okay.
Okay.
Hab sie schmerzen, aber bei ihm was als?
Ja, hab ich.
Okay.
Ja, auch ich würde gerne wissen,
leiden Sie an einem Sturrgangprobleme
oder haben Sie Probleme beim Sturrgang?
Nein, hab ich nicht.
Ich bin regelmäßig auf die Toilette,
ich hab keine Probleme damit.
Momentan mehr Probleme mit dem Wasser lassen.
Okay, klar.
Und ja, haben Sie Überkratz
oder haben Sie...
Ja, hab ich auch.
Überkratz,
habe ich auch, aber auch nicht.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwache seit drei Tagen?
Ja, hab ich ja schon gesagt seit drei Tagen.
Und das ist jetzt heute...
Ich wollte die Beilkeit fragen.
Ach so, ja, das ist heute vor allen Dingen, hab ich das erst.
Heute, okay.
Vielleicht weil ich so starke Schmerzen habe, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß, ja.
Und Oberschenkel, Sie haben erwähnt,
dass Sie auch Ihre Oberschenkel Schmerzen hat.
Ansonsten...
Ansonsten hat nicht, hat, dass Sie haben,
Sie haben nicht, dass Sie haben, Sie haben erwähnt,
dass Sie Schmerzen an den Oberschenkeln haben.
Haben.
Das ist ja auch ein Problem.
Haben Sie das an der linken Seite oder rechtsen Seite?
Halbzeit, halbzeit.
Das ist so, wissen Sie, das zieht so von der Leiste
in die Oberschenkel so rein.
So in dem Bereich.
Okay.
Leiste so richtig oben, wie soll ich Ihnen das beschreiben?
Oben, vorne, oben in den Oberschenkel.
Leiste oben.
Ja, das zieht so in die innen Seite rein.
Das fängt in den Leisten an und das zieht in den Oberschenkel rein.
Okay.
Sie haben diese Beschwerde auch seit drei Tagen?
Nee, die sind jetzt heute richtig stark geworden.
Ich hatte schon ein bisschen Schmerzen, hatte ich schon.
Aber heute, das mit der Leiste, Oberschenkel,
das habe ich schon gehabt, aber heute ist es besonders stark.
Ich habe schon ein bisschen Schmerzen,
aber heute ist es besonders stark.
Die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen hier rechter rücken,
das ist heute Nacht, also ich hatte das vor drei Tagen nicht.
Die Oberschenkelschmerzen hat ich schon gehabt.
Da bin ich auch schon viel auf die Toilette gegangen.
Aber diese Schmerzen im Rücken sind neu.
Seit heute Nacht, das ist ganz schlimm.
Jetzt kommt es wieder.
Jetzt habe ich wieder Schmerzen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen Ihnen gestartet.
Aber ja, sind Sie gegen Corona, bleibt nur eine Frage?
Sind Sie verständlich gegen Corona?
Ja, ich bin dreimal geimpft.
Und ich habe auch schon den Termin für die vierte Impfung.
Ich habe auch schon den Termin für die vierte Impfung.
Ganz gut, ja.
Okay, waren Sie im Letzterseits im Ausland?
Ich meine, in den sechs Monaten.
Noch mal Fragen bitte.
Waren Sie im Letzterseits im Ausland?
Nein, in den letzten sechs Monaten.
Nein, nein, nein.
Im letzten halben Jahr war ich nicht im Ausland.
Okay, ja.
Wir sind jetzt am Ende.
Möchten Sie etwas fragen oder etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich bin jetzt so.
Nein, ich bin jetzt so kaputt.
Ich will jetzt wissen, was ich habe.
Ich will jetzt, dass die Schmerzen weggehen.
Ja, Frau Schmidt, ich verstehe.
Was habe ich vorher noch nie gehabt?
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Ich konnte die ganze Nacht nicht schlafen.
Ich habe Übelkeit und Schmerzen.
Frau Schmidt, wir werden alles machen,
damit es Ihnen wieder gut geht.
Okay?
Ich werde die Körper und die Blutapen nehmen
und weiter die Erwärmung und die Erwärmung
und die Erwärmung und die Erwärmung
und die Erwärmung und die Erwärmung.
Ich werde die letzte Phase nochmal.
Okay.
Wenn ich alle befreien,
dann werde ich Ihnen wieder besprechen.
Okay?
Dann werde ich das mit Ihnen besprechen.
Ja.
Haben Sie liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen weitere Fragen?
Haben Sie jene Mühren,
irgendwelche Färbengänderungen
oder Auffälligkeiten bemerkt?
Habte Änderungen und Auffälligkeiten, meinen Sie?
Ja.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe auch nicht genau hingeguckt.
Ich weiß nur, dass da kein Blut drin war,
aber sonst genau habe ich auch nicht geguckt.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Wo?
Ja, aber ich habe gesagt, ich hatte einen Kaiserschnitt,
als mein Sohn auf die Welt gekommen ist.
Okay, ja.
Gerne.
Haben Sie sich noch ein Wasser lassen?
Ja, das habe ich ja gesagt.
Das brennt, wenn ich Wasser lassen muss.
Und ansonsten muss ich auch die Toilette gehen,
und das brennt richtig.
Haben Sie einen Aufschlag mit Friedrichskeitsgefühlter?
Nein, aber nicht.
Alles okay.
Ich denke, alle notwendigen Fragen wurden gestartet.
Diese Fragen, notwendig oder nicht,
haben Sie einen Unfall?
Ein Unfall?
Ja.
Hatte ich gerade mein Handy aus runter gefallen?
Nein, ich hatte keinen Unfall.
Können Arschstaatsgeschichte anfangen?
Okay, gerne.
Guten Tag, Frau Bererstin.
Ich habe Leute, hallo, eine neue Post.
Hören Sie mich?
Ja.
Frau Bererstin, ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen vorstellen,
hätten Sie dafür gesagt?
Ja, sehr gerne.
Dann schießen Sie mal los.
Es handelt sich um Uta Schimit.
Sie ist 65 Jahre alt.
70 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 80 Kilogramm alt.
Sie ist aus dem Jahr 1,75 Meter alt.
Sie kommt seit drei Tagen zu unseren Städten.
Sie hat die Städte geschmolzen.
Sie schmult im Rechten.
Durch die Rechte ist es zugesehen.
auch in der regionalen Bereiche beidseitig zu uns.
Die Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten,
aber hätten sich im Verlauf verschlimmert.
Diese Schmerzen sind kollegartig.
Die Patienten klackten über Fieber gestern Abend.
Sie hatte die Temperatur gestern gemessen.
Sie hatte das Fieber über 39 Grad gemessen.
Sie hatte seit drei Tagen Polyakisterie.
Sie leidet Schüttelfrost.
Sie hatte Schüttelfrost.
Sie hatte Fieber und Schüttelfrost.
Sie hatte die Lösung und sie hatte in Zomnia seit drei Tagen Begegnung.
Was ist in Zomnia?
Es gibt Schlafstörungen.
Schlafstörungen hat man erst, wenn man Schlafstörungen hat.
Erkrankung ist ein Artigelleparton, das seit langen
Da geht es jetzt in die Kandizarten, die 60 Millikran
Nein, nein, nein, stopp!
Kandizarten gibt es nur in zwei Dosierungen.
Man fängt an mit 4, 8, 16, 32.
Immer diese Schritte.
3, 6, 16, 32.
Das sind die Dosierungen von Kandizarten.
60 gibt es nicht.
Und dann gibt es natürlich, genau, 32.
Man kann natürlich 32 geben, ja.
Aber die Dosierung 60 gibt es nicht beim Kandizarten.
Genauso wie beim Metropole 0.
Da gibt es nur 50 oder 100 oder 47,95.
Also 16, 16.
16, 1 Millikran und Metropole 0,50 Millikran.
Nur morgens 1 Millikran.
Und sie hatte vor 32 Jahren Sex.
Ja, dann...
Über ihre Lebensgewohnheit würde ich auch etwas sagen.
Sie hat für die Zwanzischjahr...
Zwanzischjahr lang geraucht.
Nein, nein, nein, stopp!
Bitte nochmal.
Sie hat 20 Jahre lang...
Gibt es im Deutschen nicht.
20.
Die DS 20.
Unsere, ja...
20.
Guck mal, guck mich mal an.
Guck mich mal, guck mal.
Nicht.
Das gibt es nicht.
20.
Ich kann...
Ja, sardim, aber...
Ja, ich weiß.
20 Jahre lang sagt man nicht.
20 Jahre lang.
Das fehlt nicht ohne ihr.
20 Jahre lang, sie habe 20 Jahre lang geraucht.
Eine Packung am Tag.
Eine Packung am Tag geraucht.
Sie trinkt zersalzen Alkohol.
Die Fragenachdrogen wurde verneinzt.
Sehr gut.
Im Status ist vollständig.
Ja.
Und seine Iremuta ist an einem Karcinom gestorben.
Karcinom würde ich nicht sagen.
Ich habe gesagt Krebserkrankung.
Krebserkrankung gestorben.
An einer Krebserkrankung gestorben.
Was es genau ist, wissen wir nicht.
Ja, unbekannte.
Können Sie sagen, sie ist an einer Krebserkrankung verstorben.
Sie weiß aber nicht, was für ein Krebs das war.
Das weiß sie nicht.
Ja, okay.
Ja.
Und ihre Schwester leidet
mit dem Diabetes mellitus
und auch Artigalhypertone.
Sie hat novelginhalergie
und lactose intoleranz.
Ja.
Und bisherige Angaben
gehe ich von...
Stopp.
Okay.
Nach bisherigen Angaben gehe ich nicht.
Nach den bisherigen Angaben gehe ich, kann man sagen.
Bisherige Angaben,
sollten aufgeht.
Aber bisherige Angaben gehe ich.
Dieser Satz funktioniert nicht.
Okay.
Nach bisherigen Angaben
gehe ich von Piollonefritis aus.
Ja.
Nach Piollonefritis
ist das akute Piollonefritis?
Ja, akute Piollonefritis könnte sein.
Ja.
Und als Piollonefritis
denke ich an Nephrolitiasis.
Ja.
Und die dritte Diagnose?
Die Diabetes.
Nein.
Was hat sich für Beschwerden angegeben?
Wie hat gesagt, die hat Übelkeit auch?
Ja.
Ja, akute Piollonefritis.
Das müssen Sie sagen.
Genau.
Also Piollonefritis ist super, Nephrolitiasis ist super
und die Hauptdifritsialdiagnose dazu ist.
Natürlich.
Ja, dann sagen Sie schon.
Ja, das ist die Diagnose.
Ja.
Was passt denn alles zu Piollonefritis an Ihren Beschwerden?
Was passt alles zu Piollonefritis?
Ja, sie klagt über Polakisuri
und hat Fieber.
Und was ist noch typisch?
Nicht nur Fieber.
Was ist noch typisch bei der Piollonefritis?
Fieber und Schüttar.
Ja, gut.
Und das ist typische Schmerzen.
Sie hat einseitige Rückenschmerzen.
Einseitig.
Ja, zwar gesagt, es ist dürtelförmig, aber die Schmerzen sind vor allen Dingen
auf der rechten Seite.
Und was hat sie noch gesagt?
Die Schmerzen, das hat sie gesagt, kommen und gehen.
Das heißt, sie hat polikartige Schmerzen.
Und was noch für eine Piollonefritis
gesagt, Schmerzen leicht ausschreiten, denn die Oberschenkel.
Ja, genau.
Ihnen sollte von Oberchenkel.
Wissen Sie, warum?
Weil anatomisch laufen die Nerven
hinten an der Nierenbecken entlang.
Und wenn sich das entzündet, sind die Nerven auch gereizt.
Sie nach unten ziehen.
Und deswegen haben die Patienten an den Oberschenkelschmerzen.
Ganz typisch.
Ja, und Sie fühlt sich auch schwach.
Typisch, auch diese Müdigkeit,
Abgeschlagenheit, Übelkeit,
Gewichtsabnahme, passt alles.
Das stimmt auch.
Sie hat auch eine Kölonefritis.
Sie hätte es sehr einfacher gewesen, wenn Sie noch gesagt hätte,
Sie hat Mut im Urin, hat sie aber nicht.
Was sind die Hohe?
Was sind die häufigsten Erreger, hätte ich gerne gewusst,
von Ihnen, die eine pyloneftetes Auslösen können?
Ja, die häufiger Erreger sind erste.
Es ist Schiakoli.
Schiakoli, sehr gut.
Klebssela.
Klebssela ist sehr gut.
Proteus mirabilis.
Was ist das Besondere, noch eine Gruppe noch,
eine Gruppe noch, was macht noch?
Gran-negativ.
Stoffelokokon, Stöptokokon.
Ich wollte aber noch eine andere Frage wissen.
Was ist der Unterschied beim Proteus?
Was machen Sie denn, Proteus ist immer nitrit-negativ.
Nitrit-negativ.
Ist nicht nitrit-posiz, ist immer nitrit-negativ.
Ist aber egal.
Im besten Anray aufeinibere.
Ihnen ist nach der Unter Suchung?
Ja.
Könnte ich können Sie das machen?
Ich aja weiß sagen,
der Naturkurs Alystik,
Sie haben das richtig gesagt, an der rechten Flanke oder im rechten Flankenbereich.
Geht beides, sehr gut.
Entweder in der rechten Flanke, in der rechten Flanke oder im Bereich der rechten Flanke oder im rechten Flankenbereich.
Super, aber nicht verwechseln, entweder das eine oder das andere.
Okay.
Und, ob sie sonst?
Dann Sie hat FIBA auch. Ich überprüfe FIBA, Blutdruck, Perfektanz.
Wir messen die Vitalparameter, erst mal auf.
Was machen Sie noch?
Ganz einfach Untersuchung.
Wenn Sie den Verdacht haben, auch eine Pylonephritis, machen Sie sofort was?
Dann ja, wir dächchen Blutabnehmen, ürünntarzusuchungen.
Urinstatus, ganz einfach.
Was müssen Sie bei der Patientin noch machen, wenn Sie den Urinstatus abnehmen?
Sonst schimpft die Schwester später, wenn Sie sagen, ich möchte diese Untersuchung auch noch haben.
Wenn Sie einen Urinstatus machen bei der Patientin mit Verdacht und Handelichs-Update, oder was noch?
Ja, urinstatus, mittelschreie Urinstatus.
Nein, das meine ich nicht. Das sowieso immer.
Was müssen Sie immer mitmachen?
Wenn Sie den Verdacht haben, ist das sehr gut.
Urinstatus plus Kultur.
Wenn Sie mit der Antibiotese anfangen, müssen Sie vorher die Kultur haben, die erreger Resistenz.
Ja, wir müssen erregerbe
Das üben Sie jetzt nicht CRP, das gibt es nicht.
CR, CR, CRP.
CRP.
Ja, nicht p, p, p, CRP.
CRP, p, p, p, CRP.
Super.
Ja, ja.
Was erwarten Sie im Urinstatus?
Erwarte, ja, positives Nitritz und auch...
Leider ist es, aber das kann aber auch sein, dass es negativ ist, wenn es Proteus ist.
Ja, und Lokostür, ja, und Erdrossit, ja, Protein auch, kann ich bestimmen.
Nicole tritt noch, man muss es ja nicht sehen, ja, sehr gut, genau.
Was machen Sie noch an Untersuchungen?
Eine Untersuchung können Sie noch machen.
Sollten Sie auch machen.
Beider Brutal-Therzuken.
Nein, wir haben gesagt, wir sind Kultraschall.
Was wollen Sie sehen?
Ich würde beurteilen ob eine Nierenstein oder ein Hahnstau gibt.
Sie wissen, dass ein Nierenstein sehr schwer zu sehen ist.
Selbst Urologen haben Probleme mit den Schallschatten, um Steine zu sehen.
Und nicht alle Steine sind Schattengeben.
Das heißt, Sie sehen es nicht immer.
Aber was sehen Sie? Das haben Sie eben gesagt.
Nein, das ist ein Hahnstau.
Nur ein Hahnstau, nicht hier in Nierenhahnstau.
Den Hahnstau müssen Sie ausschließen.
Genau, warum?
Weil wenn das doch ein Stein ist, dann wissen Sie ja nicht.
Und der hat ein Hahnstau.
Was machen Sie dann mit den Patienten?
Wenn ein Patient ein Hahnstau hat,
dann denke ich auch, das ist ein Hahnstau.
Ja, was machen Sie mit dem Patienten,
wenn ein Hahnstau hat?
Was machen Sie?
Wenn der Patient ein Hahnstau hat,
gehört er in die Urologie.
Dann müssen Sie ihn weiterverlegen.
Ja, eine urologische Konstilveranlassung.
Ja, können Sie ihn, wenn Sie es im Haus haben,
wenn nicht, denn es ist kleinsthaus,
wie bei mir zum Beispiel,
dann muss der weiterverlegt sein in eine Urologie.
Ein Hahnstau muss terrapiert werden.
Terrapiert werden, ja.
Ja, nirgendwarte auch wichtig.
Genau, das machen wir sowieso mit.
Da sehen Sie, ob der Hahnstau hat oder nicht.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt an Therapie bei den Patienten?
Das ist eine ältere Patientin.
Deswegen würde ich das Stationär aufnehmen.
Sie fühlt sich schwach
und sie hat starke Symptome,
wie Fibar, Schutterlfrost, Emynozia und ja.
Was ist in Nausea?
Nausea.
Sagen Sie das deutsche Wort bitte dazu.
Nausea, Übelkeit.
Sagen Sie Übelkeit.
Muss ich Übelkeit sagen?
Nein, müssen Sie nicht.
Sagen Sie bitte Nausea,
dass der Prüfer Sie auch versteht.
Nausea versteht er nicht.
Sagen Sie Übelkeit, das ist einfach.
Oder Sie sagen Nausea.
Okay, Nausea.
Nicht Nausea, Nausea.
Nausea, okay.
Oder Sie sagen Übelkeit.
Dann werde ich einen Suggen ankläge.
Ich würde die stationäre Aufnahme
ehrlich gesagt bei dieser Patientin abhängen,
machen, ob sie einen Hahnstau hat.
Wie hoch das Fibar ist.
Vor allen Dingen würde ich es von den Laborwerten ausmachen.
Wenn die Laborwerte das vererbt ist,
die Leukoziden nicht so hoch sind.
Sie hat kein Blut im O-Rin.
Kann man diese Patientin auch nach Hause schicken,
wenn sie Tabletten schlucken kann.
Wenn sie keine Tabletten schlucken kann,
wenn die Übelkeit so stark ist, dass sie nicht schlucken kann.
Obwohl die Entzündungswerte nie kriegt,
würde ich sie auch aufnehmen.
Und wenn die Entzündungswerte hoch sind, auch aufnehmen.
Was ist die Komplikation bei einer Pylonekritik?
Was kann passieren?
Ja, Pylonekritis,
beide Pylonekritis, eine Erosepsis.
Genau, wir haben Angst vor der Sepsis.
Deswegen würde ich sie an den Zündungswerte hoch sind,
würde ich sie auf jeden Fall aufnehmen.
Wenn sie niedrig sind, würde ich davon abhängen,
machen einfach, wie stark, ob sie halt optimiere Schall in Ordnung ist,
ob sie Tabletten schlucken kann oder nicht.
Das können sie ja von der Klinik ausmachen.
Was machen Sie noch mit der Patientin?
Sie haben jetzt stationär aufgenommen, so jetzt die Therapie.
Ja, Therapie, Flüssigkeit, Sufo.
Schmerzmittel, sie hat eine Walgienalergie.
Deswegen würde ich vielleicht eine,
vielleicht Tromadol, oder geben.
Ja, Tromadol ist nicht schlecht.
Wenn Sie kein Haarstau und kein Steinnachweis haben,
dann braucht es ja nicht unbedingt jetzt Tromadol.
Da kann es auch Parastomol haben, wenn es hilft.
Das ist ja sehr niedrig.
Aber ansonsten würde ich auch Tromadol geben, ehrlich gesagt.
Irgendwann objagt die Derivat.
Wenn Nierenparameter normal ist,
dann würde ich Prostomol geben.
Was haben Sie gesagt?
Wenn die Nierenwerte gut sind, würden Sie Parastomol geben?
Was hat Parastomol mit den Nierenwerten zu tun?
Nur wird Parastomolverstoff wechselt über die Niere oder über die Leber?
Nein.
Sagen Sie, dass Parastomol hat mit den Nierenwerten nichts zu tun?
Sie dürfen Parastomol auch geben, wenn die Nierenwerte nicht tun?
Nein, bei den Nierenwerte dürfen Sie auch Parastomol geben.
Ganz sicher.
Nein, um Gott zu willen.
Okay, alles klar.
Also Analgetiker, nach einer analgetischen Therapie
und Sie würden Objagterevate bevorzugen.
Warum?
Sie würden Flüssigkeit geben, aber was ist das Wichtigste?
Antibiotika.
Was für Antibiotika geben Sie?
Seftreaktion.
Oder Flourochinolone.
Bei mildem Verlauf, wenn es nicht so stark ist,
kann man auf jeden Fall Seftreaktion geben,
IV, wenn man es geben will, oder Flourochinolone.
Z.B. Leber-Floxazin, sehr gut.
Wenn es ein schwerer Verlauf ist, was geben wir dann?
Ich höre es dir jetzt, aber jetzt nicht.
Bei schweren Verlauf, also bei mildem Verlauf,
mittelmäßigen Verlauf kann man Seftreaktion geben,
oder z.B. Amtspizilin plus Dolbaktam kann man geben.
Und Flourochinolone.
Wenn Sie aber einen schweren Verlauf haben,
wenn das mit Komplikationen schwerer Verlauf,
da muss man schon etwas stärkeres geben.
Was geben Sie dann?
Metronysol oder?
Metronysol ist schon sehr viel weiter.
Nein, die Pracilin-Tazobacke-Dam, z.B.
haben Sie gut gemacht, super.
Ich habe keine Fragen mehr.
Wie lange geben Sie Antibiotika?
Sieben Tage, ich glaube.
Sieben, zehn Tage.
Bei unkompliziertem Verlauf,
ganz leichtes milde Intektion, sieben Tage.
Aber ich würde immer zehn Tage geben,
bei nierenbecken Entzündungen.
Bei schweren Verläufen bis zu 14 Tagen.
14 Tage.
Und sagen Sie, der Patient hat jetzt nicht verstanden,
was für eine Erkrankung das sind.
Können Sie dem Patientin bitte nochmal in einfachen Worten erklären,
was eine Pülung der Prätis ist?
Frau Schmidt, leiden Sie einem Nieren?
Nein, nicht Frau Schmidt, leiden Sie, Sie fragen jetzt gerade die Frau Schmidt.
Frau Schmidt, leiden Sie, geht nicht.
Frau Schmidt, Sie haben viele.
Okay.
Der Patientin würde ich nicht sagen, Sie leiden,
sondern das hört sich so dramatisch an.
Die Patientin.
Frau Schmidt, Sie haben, genau.
Frau Schmidt, Sie haben eine Nieren-Entzündung.
Deswegen würde ich Sie stationär aufnehmen, wenn Sie wollen.
Was hat sich denn an meiner Nüre entzündet?
Nieren-Entzündung ist ja das heißt wegen einer Bakterieninfektion.
Haben Sie Nierenbecken entzündet?
Nierenbeckenentzündung, molzige Ursache, ist ein Handwerks-Entzündung.
Ein ganz einfacher Handwerks-Entzündung, der aufsteigt.
Ja, sehr gut. Ich folge nur das Wort Nierenbeckenentzündung.
Alles gut. Haben Sie gut gemacht?
Haben Sie wirklich sehr gut gemacht?
Ich glaube schon, dass Sie bestehen werden.
Deutsch war sehr gut.
Ich habe ganz wenig korrigiert bei Ihnen.
Sie haben das super gemacht.
Sie müssen nur bei dem Oberarzt nochmal berichten.
Sie machen das schon sehr gut, etwas langsamer sprechen.
Sie sind sehr aufgeregt.
Es kann nicht verschieden, aber sonst war alles super perfekt.
Danke schön.
Eigentlich erwarte ich eine kardiologische Fall.
Noch mal, nochmal, nochmal, wiederholen.
Eigentlich erwarte ich, ich heißt, Sie erwarten das noch.
Eigentlich habe ich einen kardiologischen Fall erwartet.
Ja, habe ich mir schon gedacht, aber ich wollte heute mal etwas anderes machen.
Ja, Sie.